What is the solution?
Is there any solutions to this?
Well,
I mean again,
I think a lot of people,
carbon is you get very weary.
You want to see solutions.
Yeah.
Um,
you want to find solutions and you want to come with that optimism of finding
solutions and you want to justify why you doing this.
Um,
what you're doing is for which is to tell the stories but to look for solutions
to this.
Um,
and it gets worried about there is three areas.
I believe that our solutions,
first,
I do agree with you on the idea of drug policy reform.
Again,
it is tough uphill battle.
I mean going back to 2012 I wrote editorials about,
you know,
one of the reasons you should legalize marijuana is because of the marijuana
come from Mexico,
which goes to cartels,
which pays for killers,
which pays for corruption.
But the same time marijuana,
a lot of United love is legalized in the United States and the violence as she
just got worse in Mexico.
So you've also got the issue of heroin,
cocaine,
crystal Meth,
fentanyl,
and you've got,
the cartels had gone to a bunch of other rackets.
Now they still crude oil,
which is a big deal.
They still billions of dollars worth of crude oil criminals down there from
pipelines can tap into a pipeline or something.
Yeah,
you could have a pipeline.
You have,
you already put in two taps,
you drill two holes in the pipeline,
you drill a hole to put,
to take the oil out.
You'd drill a hole to put water in to try and keep it a,
uh,
the,
the pressure,
the same Debbie saw as a crazy video recently,
uh,
in a,
in a small town in Mexico where a bunch of,
there was a tap open,
a really,
really bad tap,
which they always just spreading out and a bunch of people were lining up just
to pick up the oil from the pipeline and exploded and it was just like crazy
death toe.
Yeah,
I did see that from,
from,
from Nevada.
But a better way that I do believe in,
in a,
in drug policy reform,
we have to talk about this has to be on a table.
I mean,
Americans,
there's,
you know,
no one knows really what American spend on drugs,
but as the survey,
uh,
which you can find online if you just tap in,
what do Americans spend on illegal drugs?
And it is an estimate of $100 billion a year.
So you know,
that amount of money.
I haven't,
that's an estimate.
I mean it could be right.
You know,
it's hard to know.
It's a very round number,
but like $100 billion a year.
Now,
if you think about that pumping into these cartels year after year,
I mean decades.
You know how much of that,
if it's 30 billion of that guide down in Mexico,
then over 10 years,
300 billion over 30 years,
close to a trillion dollars,
that really creates this,
this monster.
But I know a secondary,
so I'm not believe in drug policy reform.
I mean,
I don't know how,
I mean Rehab,
I want to needs it because heroin addicts by a lot of heroin,
so everyone you save from that you can,
uh,
you know,
you can stop a lot of heroin and a lot of that money,
which does money goes to these people who are doing this stuff.
But a secondary I believe is his social work.
Uh,
in the neighborhoods I like I've talked to,
I've done a lot of interviews with particularly with the assassins,
with the killers,
um,
in cartels in Mexico and also around Latin America.
I've been traveling around Jamaica,
um,
Brazil,
Central America,
Colombia,
talking to law of the killers especially.
And when I sit down with them,
I try and get their life story.
Like how did they first get into this?
Because you're not born doing this stuff.
And often,
I mean,
in some cases that is the different profiles.
There's some of them.
Uh,
and that is one,
one guy,
this is done in Honduras,
which is also crazy situation,
was a guy there.
I'd actually met him before I'd met him when I was doing some reporting down
there back in 2015 and he was driving for us and he was also carrying a gun to
help protect us with a journalist too,
that I had had,
had been hit before.
We've been actually shot before.
And uh,
then I met him again after he was in Guam to tell his story,
which is kind of typical of a lot of these guys.
And he described how he been abandoned as a kid by his parents and had this real
hate that he had with the world.
Like,
and I just fucked a world.
Um,
and he described the first time that he cared out murders.
and it,
this is just the,
I mean,
he cared out late,
already did talk.
He documented all these hits he'd done and to capitations he'd done in this kind
of crazy stuff.
But the first time a cat or a murder was probably the free case when he was 14,
and they got a family,
they went into a house,
can know they got a family and they booked to the family.
And he described when he described that and then describe later on,
you know,
how he became a higher killer.
And the thing about him,
like some of these people who think they're psychopaths,
they just,
they really don't care.
But some of them really do have these conflicts inside the heart.
I think he was someone or at least about to that interview.
And he had,
it's hard to,
to balance that someone who does evil but also has been a victim as well,
a victim and the victimizer.
And you feel that pain since,
since then he's himself been been murdered.
Um,
but uh,
yeah,
he's uh,
he was,
he no one.
So how do you get social work to reach people from a very young age?
Because often they recruited into organized crime when they're 12,
13 years old.
So he butchered his family when was 14 when he,
was he stealing money from them?
Was He,
so the story would,
that was,
he said that he was hanging around with these basically street kids and one of
the other kids said,
I know where there's some money in a house,
we can get some money.
And a house.
So they went in there and killed his family and it turned out there was no money
there.
And the reason the other kid had go there was because he'd actually been living
with his family and he said they'd been abusive to him.
So he wanted to like river have revenge on his family.
Well what was so really sick of that is to when he was describing it was they
had this family and they would stop them defending themselves.
They would like take them one by one,
like pinned them in a,
in a room and take them one by one.
I'd take them out,
butcher them,
how the other ones didn't really know what was going on and think,
I mean the action itself,
but how like teenage kids can think about that stuff.
And then later on when he was talking about the uh,
decapitations he was talking about they get contracts with the capitation inside
the court.
Like they sailor,
we want this killing.
We wanted to capitate a guy.
We want this talk.
We want to see video of the guy being the CAPITEC.
We want that.
We want the guy to suffer.
Um,
when he hacks the heads off,
there's sometimes still be a moment when,
like,
when the life goes out of them and when the body is still luck,
twitching,
like he says,
they can still see luck was,
there's a bit like nerves and was like a chicken,
like a headless chicken.
There's a bit as a part when there's still like twitching a bit.
Even after they,
uh,
you know,
they've lost a kind of seven connections there.
Ooh.